opération jean paul kauffmann raconte il
s'est adressé ce matin à ses confrères
et par leur intermédiaire donc à vous
pour vous dire un peu de ce qu'il a vécu
pendant trois ans alors qu'à l'origine
il arrivait à beyrouth pour un reportage
pour l'événement du jeudi plusieurs
moments très émouvants au cours de cette
conférence de presse jean-paul kauffmann
était visiblement très éprouvé il venait
de rencontrer marie sort à la femme de
l'otage français morts à beyrouth
jérôme bonnet et plus et plus durs les
plus plus accrue de cette détention là
on sentait physiquement là la mort là
qui met vraiment mini qui tue heroes est
là autour d'eux de nous là là comme un
chien latente qui vous guide qui renifle
épique s'en va qui revient etc
c'était il y avait une présence physique
et qui était terrible qui lui gardait le
silence a eu l'oeil pareils il n'avait
pas envie de parler
visiblement fatigué jean paul kauffmann
était très ému par l'entrevue qu'il
venait d'avoir juste avant cette
conférence de presse avec marie sera les
pousses de michel sorin après de longs
remerciements à son comité de soutien
ainsi qu'à jacques chirac et charles
pasqua
kaufman a refusé pour des raisons de
sécurité de donner trop de précisions
sur les autres otages actuellement
détenu à beyrouth
est ce que vous pourriez essayer de nous
expliquer ce qui au fond de vous-même
vous a permis de tenir le coup
physiquement et moralement pendant ces
trois années d'une détention
particulièrement pénible va mal de
choses qui m'ont permis de tenir bon
manger ggg bon dieu dieu bon jeu ne nous
étions pas perdu de vue mais bon j'étais
bon je sais pas comment vous expliquer
ces c'est vrai que c'est difficile
cc c'est difficile
difficile à dire a expliqué bon et c'est
vrai que c'est un peu le piètre alors
aussi de re découvrir dieu elle dort
dans des circonstances on est dans le
malheur on balance on va en prix et qui
on se tourne vers dieu va il fallait
sans doute que ce soit fait dans des
circonstances piètre m dans ce malheur
whissell à dieu et la bible bon moment
beaucoup pds étaient très curieux
d'ailleurs parce que bon dans les livres
ou lesquels les lie au jésus a
certainement pas mal de livres
et puis on y les perdais tout le temps
dans nos 18 déménagement on les
retrouvait plus les égards etc
mais la bible elle suivait tout le temps
donc il ya dieu sait et c'est très clair
puis il ya eu la livre les livres qui
m'ont permis de survivre la littérature
ou la littérature
ça m'a permis de survivre gros moi j'ai
vécu par exemple la voyez j'ai le tome 2
devons ça fait un peu spectaculaire il
montre deuxième volume de tolstoï la
gare à fait je fais de la publicité pour
bon et ce livre là ne m'a pratiquement
jamais quitté et il est le deuxième tome
ag tenue à porter de tels sommets ce que
le premier nous l'avions il a été égaré
ça posait un problème d'ailleurs parce
que marcel carton hibon et il n'avait
pas le premier alors j'ai dû lui
raconter le premier je ne sais pas si
vous avez lu guerre et paix mais c'est
un truc compliqué alors j'ai passé quand
même plusieurs jours à être déçu mais tu
es bon tu vois natacha le prince andré
des mariés avant et cetera est bon alors
ce livre là et puis d'ailleurs il était
beaucoup plus volumineux parce qu'il a
été tellement les pages ont tellement
été tournée et puis l'été est enfin il
avait une très curieuse forme et il
avait le double d'ailleurs de ce2 de
cette épaisseur là il a dit les bons
avec ça bon
voyez par exemple ce texte là là moi ça
va toujours dans le prince andré parle
de la mort
il va mourir le prince andré il s'est
dit est ce vraiment la mort se dit le
prince andré en considérant d'un regard
neuf ans vieux l'herbe c'est la veille
de ces points dans la bataille de
borodino l'herbe l'armoise et le filet
de fumée qui s'élevait de la balle noir
tourbillonnantes et le prince andré dit
je ne peux pas je ne veux pas mourir
j'aime la vie j'aime cette herbe cette
terre il hervé ça ça me ça me faisait
pleurer